who are you
oh no colony who does you like
yes uh maybe less colors
is that pickles sandalwood
it doesn't hurt to try right disciples
don't use internet do you um
oh
you're saved
nolan frisk
what i told you to stay off our blocks
don't lay a hand on nolan again
be a good boy now
carrie that's enough
[Music]
i said stop
rhys go
you know what this is
off-brand maple syrup eh
liquid gold off-brand maple syrup
with my gold
cara's my daughter now
i don't want you hmm
i could do better
it's early in training
council leader's disappointed
he sees my mother and me
you're not your mom
brave
we're in this together
okay
i thought i'd be angry
but
it's really you
i get why you did it
i hurt you
and i'm sorry
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
hey you're not a man
you're not a weapon
you're not a weapon
it's dead okay
it's dead you're not a weapon you're not
a weapon
[Music]
in the tradition
of the guardians who came before her
the council gathers
to invite
carrie
lavinia ecker
[Music]
child of the dawn
to bear forth the responsibility
of entering into vasquez
and serving in an honored position
guarding its sacred door
[Music]
may the body of all disciples
be one
[Music]
[Music]
relax
concentrate
close
open
you'll need practice the research team i
uh
borrowed this from didn't exactly offer
guidance
i have nothing but time down here so
has my father asked about me
the council sends their offerings
you ready to taste something that'll
make your head explode
now this is
important
boil your jerk meat
in bone broth
it rehydrates it and wakes up the flavor
like it's fresh from the smokehouse
i've never seen you smile before i'm
concerned oh you'll see
um
can you cut it for me
well
now here's the best part of your arm
remember how to make a fist
devil's phone
added to myself keep it sheathed but
remember
if you strike
you strike the kill
gary
is that you
you shared me with the world tasha
against my wishes get back here you
betrayed me you said you would hide me
it's touching my neck harry wait what if
i blink i die you have to trust me now
carrie i do
of course i do tasha okay then take your
blade out
okay it's out
walk towards me but stop like two feet
away not too close
like here good step on three wait what
one
two stab one stop i said stop
are you okay
[Music]
kill it
[ __ ]
[Applause]
just be safe tashi
tashi
what
carrie are you doing nicknames now what
no be quiet oh my god care bear i'm so
proud of you
sorry sorry no i thought well no wait
are we hugging
go this way yeah
pickles sandalwood pickles
some dolly22 sandalwood it's becoming my
portable shower
thanks for everything karaoke
you don't have to go in there you know i
do
what's your plan to actually entail i
say some words the territory closes up
you just say some words
they're really good words
i'm
[Music]
okay i'll lure him out you perform the
ritual before it's too late
wait i uh
i want to see something big but my mind
is in puddles and i just
it's like blah mush i
what about and i love you i need to see
something perfect
perfect last words
what
[Music]
go tasha
go
[Music]
come on
you can do it
i believe in you
[Music]
thank you you